Martin Griffiths is the UN under
Secretary General for humanitarian
Affairs and emergency relief coordinator
he joins us now from Cairo good to have
you with us so first of all can we
expect do you expect that further trucks
will
follow uh we insist that further trucks
follow what it's been a key point of all
the extremely detailed
negotiations that have been going on
these last days and are still
continuing that an essential part of any
aid program anywhere in the world by the
way but certainly including in Gaza
under current
circumstances is about humanitarian Aid
being provided
reliably in an uninterrupted fashion to
the people who need it they need to know
how long they need to exist on the aid
that they get
today I know you insist do you have any
assurances that it will
happen well we are negotiating uh right
now as we speak for
tomorrow um and the days to come so is
there a chance tomorrow Aid might get
in there's a chance yes there's a chance
tomorrow that Aid might get in it's it's
not going to be anything like the the
the levels that you have accurately
described are needed um and we have
heard also from our colleagues in unra
which has a huge experience of course in
Gaza but yes we are hoping that Aid goes
in tomorrow we're hoping that Aid goes
in every single day and we're hoping
that it becomes Dependable reliable
efficient and at scale operation and you
refer to that um Summit held in Cairo
today I was present along with my
Secretary General Anton Gres every
single member state that spoke at that
Summit spoke of the urgent need and the
deserving
attention of the people of Gaza and of
Palestine for that humanitarian the a
that I represent all right you said
there's a a chance it might get in even
as soon as tomorrow again is there any
chance that we might see other vitals
get into Gaza particularly fuel
hospitals need fuel in order to to
operate for ambulances to operate people
need fuel and water for for for water
generators to be switched back on and so
on yeah we do we do need fuel let's be
very unequivocal about this let us not
try to be clever about it we need
fuel yes I understand that for some fuel
can be seen as a dual use commodity we
have a lot of experience in many parts
of the world in many conflicts about the
issues of importing so-called dual use
Commodities it is not beyond the bounds
of our experience and it is certainly
Central to our current
negotiations to work out a system
whereby it becomes clear monitored
transparent
andure that the fuel that we take in and
we must take it in for the reasons you
accurately pointed out will not will not
be used for war but will be used for
those essential elements of Peace the
gazen Health crisis is beyond
belief the gazen health institutions are
on their knees and Central to that
collapse is is water and the need for
water as well as medical stocks as well
fuel is needed we must have it we're
negotiating on it and I am certainly
hopeful that we will get an agreement on
that very very soon we must must how
soon Martin if I may ask how soon do you
think I don't know we need you know
we're operating day by day to be very
honest with you on these
negotiations let me just describe a
little bit about those negotiations
because I think that gives us a better
understanding we are we're in the UN and
we are operating in negotiations with
the Israeli authorities of course and
the Egyptians both very deeply involved
in the uh entry into and exit from Gaza
the United States is often behind the
scenes sometimes in front of the scenes
being extremely important and very
helpful we negotiate throughout the day
we negotiate long into the evening
negotiations will be going on long after
this program ends and I would like to
think I would like to think that by
tomorrow we will have agreement on
certain basic aspects can I take a
moment to explain what those are ple
please go
ahead so first of all fuel as you say
and I think we we're clear about that we
need fuel we need to have a regime to
demonstrate non julus number two we need
to have a an inspection regime an
inspection program so that the parties
neither of the parties either not only
just the one of them uh knows that Aid
coming in isn't going to be used for war
doesn't include weapons for example we
have this from many parts of the world
we have it in gazan just up the road for
uh in Imports into Northwest Syria for
example we have to have an agreement
agement on that in order to know our
Logistics our timing our the precise
Ambit of our needs and finally perhaps
as importantly as anything else we need
to have an upto-date picture of the
needs of the moving population in Gaza
and they need to move wherever they want
to move not where they're forced to move
but wherever they want to move and
wherever they want to move from there
too so that we can know where we need to
deliver how much money we need and how
much funding we're going to need from
all those member states who went to that
uh Summit today and others who should
help us come to the Palestinian at this
time of anguished need okay you've made
u a few really important points that I
can see some headlines coming out of
there let me try and get one other point
uh get you to comment on one other point
are you in any kind of negotiations as
well to provide some kind of I don't
want to call it ceas fire but pause in
these air strikes so that this Aid can
be delivered because what we're hearing
from correspondents and people on the
ground so far is it's it's very
difficult to get Aid out while Gaza
continues to be pounded and there I'm
sure you don't want to see this stuff
simply shipped through the border and
put in a
warehouse no sa safe
safety for people of of course exactly
as you say is about not being bombed and
being allowed to move safely with their
families to where they can live safely
and eat safely now my Secretary General
Antonio Gres repeated yet again today
not for the first time his call for what
he calls a humanitarian
ceasefire what that means is very simple
we need to have clarity about places
which will not be bombed or attacked by
anyone by either side typically by the
way civilian infrastructure hospitals
schools and so forth are actually exempt
from any attack in war by the rules of
War by International humanitarian law
you're absolutely right do I do you
think you're going to get a commitment
an agreement particularly from the
Israeli side not to to bomb certain
areas so you can distribute Aid
there yes yes we must we must we must we
you know I I'm one of those people who's
often accused of being over hopeful if
you don't hope you don't do things we
are at it day by day we have a very
powerful Ally uh in Egypt we have a very
powerful Ally in of course the United
States and much much more importantly we
have a very powerful Ally in the law so
yes and you're negotiating right now
with the
Israelis we're negotiating with all
sides we're negotiating all sides I
don't think I'm not so unrealistic to
think that we will get all places to be
safe of course not but we need one two
or three we need places where people can
feel safe where we can feel safe you
know we've lost staff as well of course
in Gaza just like the poor G and
families that you've been describing my
office has lost family members also in
Gaza the misery of Gaza is not contained
within Gaza it has spread throughout the
region so we need to have those places
of safety identified we need to know
that we can go there at certain times
safely that people can receive us safely
and that safety and I keep using the
word deliberately is about not being
attacked hence Antonio gutterz and his
repeat
strong call for humanitarian
ceasefires all right thank you so much
it's been a pleasure talking to you
thank you so much for uh highlighting
explaining what's going on behind the
scenes